all right man I know you wanted to start
with with the relationship advice hey if
you want to talk about someone else but
ya know I got black mirror season 12
mapped out what is it already I actually
read this article and just bear with the
boring [ __ ] for a second I promises
crazy
so the finance the crypto exchange yeah
this we had to leave the windows open
because Chile took a Dookie oh yeah
sorry it took a big diarrhea that stinks
yeah I guess we work by a Lamborghini
dealership I never knew that of course
you do
yeah our studios on a day were the only
podcast on road day oh man we got a tube
of Balenciaga yeah our studio rent is 15
million dollars a month is that a retail
space on the first floor if you look in
the windows on Rodeo you'll find us yes
sitting there in a bill glass soundproof
shield we built an LP tech shield unit
in a Balenciaga store on Rodin that's
how [ __ ] rich we are you guys you
don't get it
one person's gonna go Rodale and be like
I'm looking for the podcast anyways
we're talking about no so this he tweets
this clip and it's the CEO of bind up
guy so he's in like a lot of the busy
nachi videos and it's a deep fake which
is a media it's a synthesized media of
his face and like a kung fu movie and it
creeped me out because it's one of the
better ones I've seen okay and the shot
is like the camera is like it it I don't
know if it's not like steady but it's
like going around a group of people and
you can't see the break in the in the
deep fake okay I guess face looks
[ __ ] perfect on the actor and he's
talking and the actors doing a lot of
fast motions and it's his face and it's
perfect so the article is about how
media synthesis is like the next big
thing like a blockchain was a big deal
for the last five years the next thing
is media synthesis and specifically
being able to monetize media like your
face and the example he used was like
the peloton girl was a good example
where you know Ryan Reynolds is smart
for using her right away he was like I
see a future where
synthesized media will be so fast that a
person like that if they have a viral
moment any ad company could be like
would you like to be featured in this ad
and then a person acts as a plate shot
for the person and they just synthesize
the actor to the to the plate yes yeah
that's [ __ ] sick so whatever so who
knows how long that'll take
yeah it's not sick but it's also sick
yeah concept than he was saying he's
gonna just [ __ ] destroy it's gonna
ruin that like the integrity of
advertising yeah completely yeah oh my
god dude I mean every [ __ ] Brad
Pitt's face on on an M&M and they did it
overnight Oh imagine is this stupid [ __ ]
that's gonna happen because of that that
was my first thing is like Dipel imagine
like just getting devalued instantly
yeah by like you get a viral moment and
add companies dude what if like I
started getting like weird like thoughts
about like what if like an agency like
when you sign to them they can license
out your face for me that's what it's
gonna be I mean yo you're gonna have to
own your face yeah
and then the rights to use your face and
just people will buy those from you or
own them just wake up in commercials you
don't agree with yeah exactly what have
you i I don't some actors really
struggling and they just sell all rights
forever oh yeah you know man Brad Pitt
after he signed the rights away to his
face that [ __ ] fell off he's in
everything Pedialyte Gerber a
spokesperson for like a herpes
medication or some [ __ ] yeah just oh
wait that's a sketch isn't it yeah I
mean I don't know there's also like I
don't mind that'd be so funny he was
walking on the grocery store and he sees
his face on on diarrhea meds yeah well
the next day like what the [ __ ] you know
that whole [ __ ] meme someone this is
in a movie or whatever or I think it
actually happened but like a boxer
advertising like pain pills after they
get knocked out oh yeah yeah the next
day like hella advil commercials Mike
Tyson hey come on man I'm cowboy I'm
Donald cowboy Cerrone and I got my [ __ ]
clap last night you know the first thing
I got was [ __ ] advil extra-strength
so whatever so and now I'm here to tell
you about the softness of these
baby blanket I need a nurse myself my
nurse my [ __ ] broken nose backpack to
help ya man
so then he started going in on like you
know your face will become like I'm like
almost like currency like it's gonna
have value and which I didn't think that
was like a genius observation that kind
of is the case already like that's an
actor right like an actor's voice yeah
you know what I've way more so now
because yeah physically be there so I
just started thinking of like really
stupid [ __ ] one I was like you know I
want someone to take the bachelor a
whole season of The Bachelor but
synthesized the bachelors face onto all
the girls and rename all the girls to
the dude so he's just dating himself for
like 12 season and see if anyone is like
into it then the thing I want so he kind
of touches on like AI articles and AI
media and like I've seen like AI
generated journalism is bad but I want
so someone did a media synthesis just
with audio with Joe Rogan yeah or any
computer science nerd
yeah listen to the podcast I want you
now we have what we have like over a
hundred episodes
yes no I want someone to synthesize an
episode based on our audio yes one yep
to take our faces from like all the
videos we've done and synthesize us into
a weird space right yeah like on the two
actors yeah you know having a fake
conversation yes that was all
synthesized yeah do that
yeah somebody [ __ ] do that please
you're a nerd cut yeah if you're if
you're a stupid little nerd your stupid
little back-end developer a little dumb
[ __ ] puny little backend [ __ ] boy
please do that yeah please if you're a
dumb [ __ ] cognitive science major
put that together you [ __ ] idiot we
beg you you stupid little nurse doofy
little [ __ ] dumbass playing with
computers all day well come on you
little [ __ ] do it I used eggs as well
stand up he see what Jose Raymond said
to the man he was saying I would say
some [ __ ] about the computer maybe like
can't you like can you do that for me I
don't like bro you don't know how to do
this on a computer he's like he's a
mangrove in a hood I wasn't a finger
[ __ ] computers like you fingers I
just thought about just doing like a
floppy
drive with two greasing up your fingers
into the CD drive hey mama mmm pressing
the CD disc tray out and putting it back
in slip
forcing it back in against the engine
come on Noel softer ow
you're hitting my back wall ow it's okay
okay you're hitting my C Drive I'm to
capacity please stop
take it no please do that
[ __ ] the Twitter account no no don't
[ __ ] this one down because that's really
funny
but the tweet tweet bots are are old
news yeah you know Society B mod and it
is funny yeah but we need real
conversation we need us having a full-on
conversation about whatever it is that
we [ __ ] talk about I don't know what
it is that's what I want to see yeah
what we'll see what we talked about but
I'm going to learn uh-huh have you eaten
all the episodes and let's see that'd be
[ __ ] dope yeah and and then we are
then we just inevitably fire ourselves
from our job because when this
synthesized an idea for like the show
Ike I wonder if we could actually pay
someone to do this what for the live
show like create an asset like this
where it's like oh yeah yeah that's what
I was thinking damn that's that's a
great idea yeah yeah do we I mean we got
to leave this in yeah of course yeah
yeah I'm just saying that's a great idea
yeah so if your comp sign nerd of you AI
nerd hit us up you're gonna want to do
something [ __ ] crazy I'll be Dolph
we'll pay you you little [ __ ] yeah
we'll pay you dumb [ __ ] fine you drive
a hard bargain we'll pay you you just
add homeless very sick oh I'm paid fine
$1,000,000 fine twist our arm ten
trillion dollars yeah so
you